now it is number and at their door from mine
when we talk about rooster in the
conception of a good part of the
population in central southern spain
the engagement is an animal if you can more
inferior than normal dogs are
considered agricultural commodities working animals
this association  was born with the intention
of supporting a Spanish refuge
fondacion benjamin friday fbm precisely
that deals with redeeming save and
treat Spanish greyhounds called galgo
these dogs are reproduced in
an exaggerated way to obtain the
samples that can participate in
clandestine racing competitions or the
simulation of the  hare hunting
all those that are considered scraps
are then abandoned perhaps in the
best of cases mistreated or killed and
thrown into wells or even hanged
go
we decided to adopt a gorgo because we
love day of life and we like this kind
of web mymamy dacic i  want to adopt a
gago heinze afraid of things
the horror of add that but when paloma
count  to my house ai understand that
week end
the first meeting was beautiful
because I didn't expect to see
dog and she is mine
and it was beautiful because we saw each other
I sat on the ground she
hugged me and we loved each other
times of india
in the park experience with this is very
funny cheese intelligent she's so
lovely and food for italici and  also the
family mad dog lei paloma and change
what she does together for sbm with three purposes
operating in italy the first purpose is to
support and tell the sad story
of the life and to support the
benjamin meinert foundation our second
purpose is to find volunteers who
want to live a  experience in the center
of the problem and our third activity
is to find adoption for some of these
dogs
we want that the rooster no longer
exists.  o they are 80,000 and 100,000
Spanish and Cisliano galgos we would like to
clarify that this is not
a real strudel it is a
backward mentality
so we have to fight against
a mentality
jobs how to vote